it's time for the final five
all right
scarlett what's your most irrational
fear my most irrational fear
i i i well i don't know i used to be
like i'm never going to work again
i would finish a job and then be like
that's it well i had a good run and i'm
never going to work again
so yes that's a good one it's kind yeah
it's bad no good but it's understandable
and relatable um okay if you could see
into the future what would you want to
know
um i would want to know
if trump is going to run again
i just want to know so i can be prepared
i'm going to bet yes i feel like that's
probably going to happen no oh well i i
i don't know if i can handle it i just
don't know
sorry i know this is like a divisive
topic but
i i i need to you would like to mentally
prepare i need to be mentally prepared
that's all that's all i'll say all right
i get that um okay uh what is something
that you hope your kids never find out
about you um why i'm supposed to say
that
oh yeah that does defeat the purpose i'm
trying to think what would i not want my
kids to find out i'm sorry
i ate a ton of bugs earlier and they're
that was so
nasty i cannot
oh my gosh it was actually making me
sick watching you i have to tell you
they were delicious they they needed a
little salt other than that they were
great there is no possible way i could
do that they were really good actually
no they weren't i swear i swear i would
eat them on a salad
crunch crunch no
would you yes i think i would oh
no also like
um okay okay
something your kids hope never oh you
know what i well
i don't know my daughter may have asked
me this before i used to smoke when i
was younger and i'm so like like i just
don't want her to ever think that i ever
thought it was cool because she can
never ever ever smoke
and um because that's what you do you
forbid your kids from doing things and
then they don't do them
and um so yeah i i just hope she never
kind of figures that out all right when
are you the most competitive
uh i am the most uh when i'm playing
backgammon it's great i love back i mean
i so colin and i started playing
backgammon a couple of years ago um
i think because we had like somebody had
given us a board or like our ch one of
our checkerboards or something was like
also a backgammon board like i've always
wanted to know how you played this game
it's pretty easy to learn it
and collins annoyingly wins
all he wins at everything and it's so
annoying anyways just like even every
like the he'll last minute like roll a
bunch of doubles and you're like why
there's no way like how is this
happening he's so lucky um
and but he also has been playing it on
his phone and it's like that's not fair
that's cheating he's picking up all
these like
tools that he would never otherwise have
because he's like playing on his phone i
don't like it hmm i don't like it makes
me want to like find like a backgammon
champion and like get them to you
secretly so you could like brush up on
tips
we'll talk
text you later
okay last question is it true that you
can cry on command
um i could tr i could try
i i probably could ish
hi
wanna try
you're going to a dark place
it's true i only ever cry when i start
talking about like my daughters
you know okay so you're gonna go there
i'm gonna go there okay like i didn't
think that i could
i didn't think that i would ever have
the opportunity to
have the experience in life that i
didn't have with my mom you know and i
it really just messes me up and i've
it's like a chance to
to get things
um
you know not right because they were
never wrong i loved my childhood
wouldn't change it for a thing
but it's like all of a sudden i just
have this magical ability to
um i'm still thinking about you i'm like
i'm half there but i have big attention
oh my god there goes the roll the tear
came out
it came out you win
you win
both here you did
rolling out i was on the surface because
i'm half in like half paying attention
nicely done
johansen
got the roll
anybody tuning in right now is going to
be like these people are so super
like
that's every day on this show
we like we like to be weird and have fun
and get deep and such a great show i am
so excited for you and so
like that you're where you're supposed
to be it's just wonderful
i will say in all sincerity i almost
cried when you came out because i was
like proud to show you like what we've
been doing here
[Music]